thank you very much I should say that
after our next speaker were delighted to
have yells political science eminence
professor Dougray author of City a
remarkable book that deals with the
origins of some of these problems in our
very own City who will moderate the
questions afterwards but first calm
Vanderbilt okay great I can everyone
hear me okay great to see such a big
turnout here it was just at a conference
down in Austin for the Texas Department
of Transportation and one of the
commissioners there was decrying what he
thought you know the view of
transportation as essential important
it's our lives the transportation in the
app to the average sort of person as he
put it I thought a very Texas way is
about as sexy as putting socks on a
rooster but and so in to use Don's
analogy of dogs and cats I tend to think
I was more sort of a pigeon kind of
flitting about the streets picking up
what I could here and there from all
sorts of different aspects of traffic
and this is the book I've written down
as one of the many people in it people
whose work I was really trying to bring
to this wider public and I'm not a
journalist by training no background in
transportation planning or anything like
that just the presence of this year is
making me very nervous he's all sorts of
things I would typically skip in a lot
of transportation papers and get to the
conclusion find out the truth but so
anyways this is the book I've written
it's been published in a number of
different countries which has been
published a number different countries
which is interesting i'm sorry switch to
this and this is a fascinating process
that would not would not without a few
moments lost in translation the if you
notice the german edition down here in
the lower left-hand corner they went
with the title auto instead of traffic
and i called a publisher I so this is a
little bit I'm curious about this it's
not really a book about the car tomorrow
bout traffic you said well Tom and in
german the word traffic is actually
synonymous with the word for intercourse
I spent a few minutes on the phone
trying to explain why this actually
wouldn't be a bad thing to confuse in
the mind of a consumer but he didn't buy
that so i just wanted to begin so I live
in Brooklyn I have a particularly unique
relationship to parking I I do own a car
which is a very strange thing and we
have a very interesting form of what's
called transportation demand management
in New York City which is that you
basically don't leave your space you
don't ever drive because of fear of not
only losing the great space you have but
of encountering the sort of angry
natives when you return and do something
wrong but this you know even with in New
York a minority of car owner New Yorkers
actually own cars but even within New
York there's interesting variations
between neighborhoods I know there's a
Jackson Heights resident former jackson
heights residents here somewhere an
interesting study looked at two
neighborhoods in Brooklyn says where I
live and you know if you were a
transportation planner sort of looking
at this you might go up and down the
line here and think that well park slope
here it's a wealthier part of town
there's actually more cars there
certainly they must be sending more
vehicles to the central business
district in fact it was actually Jackson
Heights on about sound like forty
percent more people were actually
driving to the central business district
and the reason was is that Jackson
Heights people tend to have little
parking spaces protected the curb cuts
they have garages so this is you know
something that the mere presence of this
protected parking spot embolden them to
drive and change their behavior in a way
that you know it's sort of economics
when I want incentives matter where as I
I'm quite afraid to ever drive anywhere
this you know this is sort of 1970 image
sort of the high point of getting over
the city to the automobile and I'm a
child of the early 1970s and it's been
interesting to sort of note the bit of
unsustainable path we've been on and we
talk about the American love affair with
the automobile but you know and some
people joke that it's long ago long ago
turn into a marriage but it's
interesting for me to track how how much
this has changed even in the past few
decades since i've been around but
another way to look at parking here this
is brian pigeon house key a geographer
at purdue who did a sort of a heat map
here of all the available parking spaces
in Tippecanoe County Indiana these are
just the municipal sort of parking lot
this isn't residential stuff you found
there basically three times as many
parking spaces as there were actual
residents in the town that the parking
parking lots occupied twenty percent
more space than the businesses they
served that if you were to extend this
relationship to the country to the to
America Connecticut and Massachusetts it
have to be turned entirely into parking
lots and that basically if everyone in
this county got up and drove around at
the same time there would be something
on the order of 250,000 parking space is
still available so just sort of sitting
there so massive sort of overabundance
of of parking and and i should say road
space the rand RAND Corporation has
estimated that ninety percent of
American roads are not congested ninety
percent of the time so but you know this
is another thing that's changed
remarkably in 1960 this was almost
unheard of a three-car garage now one in
five new home starts has one of these
and what's interesting is that this sort
of relationship began to change even as
American households were getting smaller
and arguably houses should have been
getting smaller but sort of speaks to
the idea that we sometimes hear talk
about population increase contributing
to congestion in some case it does but
what's really changed over the past few
decades is this incredible increase in
vehicle miles traveled which is bmt of
course from nineteen sixty eight to two
thousand the population grew about forty
percent the number of vehicle miles
traveled increased one hundred and sixty
percent so I I sort of and most of this
i should say was what's called
discretionary driving this is not
work-related commuting this driving so i
tend to blame the rise of organized
youth soccer for the sort of the vast
increase that was going on here but
there's some other things kind of rising
at a similar rate during that period and
we lay us we lay a lot of blame at the
foot of sort of corn syrup and and
things like that but you know clearly
there's this tracks the VMT increased
pretty well and Sheldon Jacobson has
pointed out that as Americans have
gotten heavier this is of course you
know sort of perverse feedback loop our
fuel economy has declined because it
requires more energy to move these
heavier Americans around so sort of a
negative feedback loop of course we have
ways of counteracting these this obesity
think this is
we drive to the gym and this is an
actual as a San Diego actual actual gym
some people think this photo is dr.
about proud this from Dan burden because
a great image but now this talk about
being a child of the 70s is an iconic
house The Brady Bunch house and we think
about you know suburbia obviously people
do more driving but even again in these
past few decades as a measure of how
things have changed the Brady Bunch
house on the Walk Score website
interestingly scores an 82 which is not
the ninety-eight percent that my
Brooklyn neighborhood does but it's
still pretty decent compared to what's
come along since then which is places
like Henderson Nevada one of the
epicenters of the subprime crisis where
you're getting walk scores in the
neighborhood about 50 so now just
another thing that has changed in that
time first McDonald's drive-thru came
around in 1975 I always thought this
happened much earlier but McDonald's now
does a majority of their business
through the drive-thru so McDonald's a
sort of a nice little icon of car
dependency McCants has become a car a
dependent country so these demographic
things are interesting what wasn't
wasn't what really motivated me to write
the book what really motivated me was
just some sort of questions I had as a
long time driver participant in this
this environment that I think is so
ubiquitous and yet so overlooked and I
was trying to sort of understand some of
things about the behavior of other
drivers about the way traffic work to
sort of understand this environment and
so I had simple questions in mind that I
wanted to ask and I want to show you a
clip from a film that I think
demonstrates one of these traffic
phenomena quite well we could just go
through this as an office space
phenomenon I'm talking about is the
sensation you may have a strategy at the
other
okay so now this is a really a real
phenomenon I think we've all experienced
and what's interesting though is that
some some Canadian researchers actually
identified what was going on here is an
interesting cognitive illusion because
about ninety percent of our time spent
in driving is we're looking forward
which sort of makes sense there's
something that happens by which we
actually spend more time watching other
vehicles physically pass us than we see
ourselves passing other vehicles this
illusion is made worse by the closer we
drive to the car in front of us and the
more glances we make in the neighboring
lane it increases the sense of this
illusion so we always sort of feel like
we're coming out on the losing end in a
traffic situation this I think plays
into what Daniel Kahneman is called loss
aversion by which the human brain
actually registers losses much more
powerfully than it does gain so and this
is a case if you talk many traffic
engineers they would say well in many
cases we better if no one actually
change lanes what what seems best for
the individual user user optimality
actually makes the system work this
guy's probably changing lanes because
someone did what he did about a mile
ahead and there's sort of a called a
butterfly effect that can happen that is
almost version of chaos theory so now
another question I had was this idea of
congestion does it was always an
instance of there not being enough
capacity was there always a bottleneck
was there's a result of an accident and
on ramp adding new vehicles on to a
system some Japanese physicists did a
fascinating experiment they got a closed
track and asked a group of drivers to
maintain a steady speed and following
distance and keep us up for as long as
they could and you'll see that because
humans are not robotic devices that over
time a bit of sort of noise begins to
enter the system people begin to drive
closer they fail to react in time they
overreact they break harder than they
should and out of this sort of perfect
closed system stop and go congestion
begins to emerge just through the sheer
actions of drivers and it's interesting
modeling done we're looking at people on
cell phones because you have a delayed
reaction people on cell phones actually
uh actually exacerbating the situation
of making worse now there is a solution
that's out there which I wrote in in New
York about a year ago this is a vehicle
called jr. which is the Stanford
University entry in the DARPA urban
challenge race fully autonomous
volkswagen passat
for a few blocks in him jr. can sort of
see everything around with lidar on a
variety of sensors unlike many New York
City drivers he actually has full
compliance with various traffic signals
like stop signs and after a few blocks
you sort of get used to the idea that
you're being pilot around by this
automatic vehicle and of course jr.
would have no trouble maintaining the
steady speed and following distance oh
this is one version of the future which
is coming now another idea of the way we
contribute to our own traffic problems
of course the famous one is rubber
necking and some some dutch researchers
sent me this a while ago and they did
interesting experiment for a crash to
happen on a dutch highway and this was a
van roll over on the top here and
luckily not not fatal but what you see
is obviously there's a capacity drop in
the top section here people are having
to move over who's some merging activity
there's about a twelve percent reduction
I think estimated but what's interesting
this was a physical bottleneck but if
you look at the very wide median strip
across there there's actually vehicles
are slowing exactly where the van is
there's sort of a mental bottleneck that
has emerged and they also modeled that
the drivers were emerging from this
queue slower than they would in normal
stop and go congestion so who did that
accident is having an effect on them
they're sort of distracted perhaps
pausing to contemplate their own
mortality and this is something we all
sort of know anecdotally happens but
it's nice to see the actual data out
there and have the stuff modeled so the
reviewer for the New York Times
suggested that my book should be called
simply idiots and this was one one one
question I was tasked with which was why
people seem to do these dumb things on
the road as a California Highway Patrol
officer put it to me why we seem to act
as if you're suffering from a cranial
rectal inversion but part of the problem
I think as we often underestimate the
complexity of driving either it's been
estimated for example at every two miles
the average driver makes 400
observations 40 decisions and one
mistake but the idea and I was really
trying to get to this idea that the jock
tati got to and is this film traffic
which I would recommend if you haven't
seen it which is the idea that we become
different people when we enter an
automobile and I've clearly you know for
the traffic engineers in the house
tonight managing traffic and mobility
has sort of a long
standing problem mrs. image comes from
the ruins of Pompeii you see the chariot
ruts still expand on the street people
they've put these sort of walkways
across there so pedestrians can cross
without being drenched by mud and you
see it's lined up perfectly so that the
chariots can cross through these
crossings there's kind of an interesting
echo of today's speed cushions which
traffic calming devices which have nice
cuts so emergency vehicles can drive
over them faster than normal cars so
Pompeii even had some early bollards
devices to block vehicles from using
certain streets and this idea of
managing different modes of mobility and
tension on the road road road rage the
modern praised its impact on modern at
all this is Claude geo painting for the
19th century and just when things some
managing these various modes as long
standing in a long-standing problem and
just what it seemed that as if things
could not get more complicated on the
road Along Came this new form of
personal mobility the first real
innovation since Caesars Rome which
upset this fragile balance talking here
about the bicycle of course this
credibly controversial device in the
late 19th century the New York Times
declared them rubber shod missiles of
the highway horse carriages didn't want
them in the street pedestrians didn't
want them on the sidewalk where do you
put this thing strange new etiquette
questions should men yield to women and
and so this is ancient sort of problem
and it brings up something that's been
termed a modal bias which when you enter
a car in this idea that you become
transformed to another form of person
this comes from the motor mania which is
a Walt Disney short for the 1950s I
think it's at this wonderfully it stars
goofy the dog begins life is mr. Walker
very sort of innocent person wouldn't
hurt anyone becomes a homicidal maniac
the moment he enters weather's a will
there's a way
so I think you know humans have trouble
often looking outside of ourselves and
there's something that psychologists
talk about which is called the
fundamental attribution error but sort
of in which we we basically attribute
the actions of others something about
their nature or their character and
we're asked to explain our own actions
we attributed to situational factors you
fell I was pushed as I was a nice phrase
to sort of summarize this and I think we
see this in driving a lot in part
because of stress America's are often
acting on such imperfect information we
make judgments based on the slightest
bit of external information such as a
person's license plate and this is one
of iron laws of driving in America the
worst drivers are always in the
neighboring state and sometimes we get
this information quite wrong interesting
ways when my favorite studies looked at
showed students looked at 22 clips of a
car being driven a BMW and a sort of
smaller VW they're asked a week later to
estimate the speed that each vehicle is
traveling at for a majority of subjects
said the BMW must have been driven
faster in fact they were driven at
exactly the same speed so we have the
sort of mental models of what's
happening out there that often don't
correlate to reality so now one classic
problem with traffic and driver behavior
is anonymity and psychologists also talk
about seeing the online disinhibition
effect on which we sort of sign on to an
anonymous chat room word protected
behind a username that is not our own
we're free to sort of act how we want to
act without any repercussion I think you
can think of traffic in this way with
millions of sort of anonymous users
interacting daily protected by our
license plates and this you know sort of
we don't we do not see the same people
twice in traffic which is sort of a
obvious thing but it brings up to some
interesting experimental games that have
been done in economics looking at trying
to get people to cooperate when you have
to do things like contribute money to a
common pool the cooperation rate seems
to soar when people have the ability to
punish people in later rounds so in
traffic we sort of lack this this
accountability the ability to punish
other people and of course served with
some websites that have come up
where you can sort of you know make
comments about other drivers but not a
lot of people actually look at these
systems which makes it tricky so now
somewhat related problem is
overconfidence drivers are famously
overconfident and one place
overconfidence flourishes is in the lack
of a face of feedback on pilots airline
pilots are trained rigorously on the
importance of accepting feedback from
their co-pilots drivers are less
receptive to this sort of feedback from
their passengers to put it politely but
passengers are our literally life-saving
devices studies have been done solo
drivers are involved in crashes at a
higher rate than people with passengers
one reason passengers are so good for us
they provide something we're often
missing in driving which is feedback and
interesting work done neurologically
looking at the at the mind of a driver
while they're in a simulated driving
environment versus a passenger entirely
different neural networks being
activated they are in essence different
people on the notion of feedback up for
the last few months had a small device
plugged into the onboard diagnostic port
on my car which measures which is that
thing that sort of mechanics look at
when your check engine light goes on and
actually has a lot of interesting
information that courses through that
that's pretty much ignored and with an
accelerometer and a GPS device this
little device I've plugged in their
tracks my driving tells me all sorts of
things about it gives me a report card
at the end of the month things like hard
braking jack rabbit starts even idling
and idling is one of these you know the
sort of American Idol is we consume the
amount of energy that Costa Rica extends
in a year just by to the power excuse me
just by our idling so you know often
people aren't aware of this behavior and
feedback is another mechanism to make
them aware and I've sort of even driving
up here today the CEO of this company
whose name is David I sort of have
started to call the device David it's
sitting in my car I sort of feel like
he's watching over me as I'm driving
someone cuts in front of me I have to
brake harder than I want to I sort of
think David's going to think I was
driving recklessly but it was really
that person's fault so one problem with
feedback those delivering it effectively
and again in Clifford Nass at Stanford
has done it some interesting research
for BMW dunno when male drivers were
given warnings by a female
voice in their car that they're driving
need to be improved they're driving
actually deteriorated so another problem
of traffic is that we lack traditional
signals for human communication which
Americans particular are constantly
trying to say things to one another but
i think that traffic is sort of a living
laboratory of human interaction i took
this image in beijing a place where one
form of transportation yielding to
another quite literally but it's placed
thriving with these sort of subtle
displays of implied powers basically a
giant applied psychology laboratory and
this is a you can see this at work in
parking lots appropriately one my
favorite studies looked at people who
are waiting to vacate their parking
space they found that when this was
actually measured when another driver
was waiting for that driver to leave the
parking space the person took longer to
leave that space than when no one was
waiting even though in surveys they said
they they wouldn't do this but another
great place to see this a behavior at
work is Adam intersections traffic
lights and psychologists will do an
interesting experiment will they'll stop
a car at a red light weight to the light
turns green and then not move that
vehicle and then measure who's sort of
behind there how quickly they honk how
many times they honk how long each honk
is because honking you know it's sort of
a subtle language going on there and
find that the patterns are not decidedly
not random man honk more quickly than
women people in expensive cars are
quicker to the horn than people driving
more modest vehicles people in
convertibles of the top down were less
likely to honk than others when the
driver had to appear to be from a
different country and when the driver
ahead appeared to be on a cell phone
this generated a faster honk then in
other other conditions excuse me so you
know there's all sorts of these you know
almost subconscious behaviors going out
there as we move around without and we
don't necessarily think about it one of
the things that fascinates me about the
traffic environment this is a guy named
Ian Walker who was also in the book of
traffic psychologists from England did
an interesting set of experiments rode
around on his bike hooked up with a
sensor which measured the distance of
passing cars he was bicycling he wrote
in different variety of different
conditions he
put a helmet on he did not put a helmet
on and they more sort of a what he
deemed to be a feminine wig and found
that people's passing distances varied
with each condition when he had the
helmet on driver has passed more closely
to him than when he was not wearing the
helmet and when he had the feminine wig
drivers actually gave him more space
this might have just been confusion that
it was actually Weird Al Yankovic but
that's just now another thing that ian
has talked a lot about is the importance
of eye contact in the traffic
environment and something that we don't
that's why I think about that much but
something that is generally missing if
you look at the image on the left not
sure if this works way in the back there
but something probably looks a little
bit off about this image and what's
happening is that Ian's one of his eyes
is slightly shifted by a few pixels out
of a field of hundreds and we're
incredibly sensitive this we can sort of
pick it out from across the room and
psychologists have even done I tracking
experiments where they look at where
people are looking when they first look
at an image of a car and they're fun of
their eyes are drawn to the headlights
which resemble eyes and there's a good
reason we're so sensitive to the
icontact because an important tool in
gaining social cooperation and a lot of
studies have shown this one my favorite
took place in the university break room
there was a honor system for paying for
coffee take your coffee put in the
requested amount and about the coffee
machine they put on alternating weeks an
image of human eyes or an image of
flowers and you see on the weeks that
the human eyes were there that the
donations actually sword and obviously
they don't need to be real human eyes
and week number one interestingly had
sort of the highest compliant rate
compliance rate there with these sort of
scary set of eyes so will this work in
traffic is sort of an interesting
question this is a from a artistic
traffic-calming project in st. Paul
Minnesota which is actually been pretty
successful and they've just renewed it
but so you know thinking one of the
themes in the book is how people sort of
react to the road environment as a piece
of design and how this has sort of been
neglected I think by traffic engineers
over the last few decades but as
becoming to be viewed with more
importance and instead of simply
erecting more signs we're beginning to
think about other ways we can inform dry
about how to behave in certain
environments and when I began this book
this was something that I sort of grew
up with and still see all over and I
thought it wasn't that nice people
people are sort of care about our
children they're they're out there sort
of trying to protect them and it turns
out that these signs have been shown to
do absolutely nothing at all in terms of
speed reduction or improve the safety of
children they've sort of been banned
from the official metc D because they
essentially don't work what usually
happens that people are complaining
about people driving fast down their
Street they call the local engineers who
put up one of these a sort of a parental
pacification device and and then walk
away enough speed management is sort of
a huge issue huge issue in America where
new york city we're about to try to get
a sort of 20 mile an hour speed limit
campaign going 2020s plenty is the idea
here but a lot of different approaches
to managing speed what interesting one
here in japan and melody road it
features feedback that if you drive over
it at the proper speed it plays a song
if you don't drive over it it doesn't
play the song so just another approach
in Durham North Carolina now one reason
you know to think about why drivers
might be speeding is that there's a
variety of sort of visual illusions that
happen when we're in the car and this is
my favorite illusions is essentially
called the treadmill effect the idea
here is to start the X in the center as
carefully as you can very closely as you
can and if it works you should see the
Buddha sort of loom out at you as i
working for everyone and you know what's
going on here is that the it's similar
to the treadmill in a gym and you run on
it for a while then you stop and the
room seemed to search backwards when you
drive at a higher speed at a certain
speed for a good amount of time and then
attempt to slow down the longer you've
been driving it at higher speed the
longer it actually takes you to slow
down for your brain to sort of mentally
catch up the neurons that track forward
and backward motion are getting confused
sort of a long story but engineers you
know sort of our forced to put up these
dynamic signs that actually remind
drivers of how fast are going as they're
entering an environment but another
problem though is that a lot of people
are living on the streets like this and
no matter what signs
an engineer is going to put up on a
street like this the street is sending a
variety of it not so subtle messages
that this is an environment for cars I
don't know why there are traffic lights
on this particular street but one of my
favorite phrases a Canadian engineer and
in Ezra howre says drivers adapt to the
road they see and this road is clearly
sending a very strong message about how
to behave it reminds me of a concept
that Cornell University researcher Brian
wanza calls portion distortion that he's
shown in studies that people consume
measurably more food when it's served
them in a larger package more so than
they actually even want he's done
experiments with stale popcorn and movie
theaters people consume more stale
popcorn when they eat it out of a larger
bucket so I think a lot of American
roads suffer from a version of this
portion distortion they're over
engineered for safety people drive fast
and then we're confused when people were
surprised when people consume all the
extra safety that's been built in so
this is another image from a small town
in Texas this is something that has been
happening around the country sort of
street trees often like this or are sort
of torn out is this is the tree a hazard
or is the tree in fact a safety device
yeah I can sort of guarantee the moment
you take that tree out speeds are going
to increase which is probably going to
pose a greater risk to any any
pedestrians or cyclists on that on that
street the tree is sort of an obvious
has right but because of various legal
liability issues we've been tearing
these things out I think to our to our
detriment throughout the country now I
could go on about the problems of signs
/ signage sometimes we don't actually
aren't able to see them sometimes they
sort of state say the sort of obvious
sometimes they send sometimes we
selectively obey signs based on what we
want to do and then sometimes we simply
don't understand what they're trying to
tell us I I seen this one in London all
the time and every time I come across
that I feel like I'm having a midlife
crisis I need to
it should be on a cubicle wall or
something giving me a you know positive
life direction but you know when my
favorite studies looked at had people
try to the point here is that people
often don't understand what signs are
telling them but when a favor studies
had people look at a watch for falling
rocks time half the driver said they
would look for rocks falling in the
moment and speed up half said they would
slow down and look for rocks already on
the road so I sometimes wonder if
engineers really just need to sort of
spell out everything now I'll conclude
with perhaps one of the most absurd
warning sign cases this involved a moose
advisories in Newfoundland Canada there
was a foggy stretch of road that was
home to not only many car moose
collisions but many collisions between
cars and cars stopping to take pictures
of moose so signs engine is triggered
how can we combat this problem they
erected full-size reflective silhouettes
of moose thinking that this would would
call a help a situation unfortunately
trysts found these pretty interesting
too and as they slowed herself to take
pictures of the Moose signs the Moose
signs themselves became crash hotspots
the next logical step and I wish this
were a joke it actually isn't was to
create new signs that read caution moose
science ahead so you know just take a
look at the signs you see around you and
wondering you know who's looking at them
what are they actually doing and I think
signs I've come to think represent a
failure of imagination both symbolically
and literally and how to change behavior
there's evidence that context and
environmental cues can be just as if not
more powerful behavioral economists
Richard Thaler and cast umpteen have
been arguing in their book nudge that
pushing people in the right direction
through what they call choice
architecture can have powerful effects
often more powerful than actually
spelling out what people are supposed to
do they have a favor example of this
which is the urinals in the men's
bathroom at schiphol airport in
amsterdam this seems strange but
apparently the management was upset with
having to do excessive cleanups of men's
careless behavior in the bathrooms at
the airport so they painted this sort of
a fly device here and there was within
weeks there was a measure
improvement in the cleanliness of the
bathrooms man we're encouraged to aim
for this so no signage was required a
very simple subtle bit of choice
architecture here and you think you know
how does this apply to the world of
traffic well there's been tremendous
ting things like Chicago's lakeshore
drive the curb at oak street beach home
to a crash hot spot for a number of
years people tend to treat Lake Shore
Drive like a of Interstate Highway even
though it's meant to be about 35 miles
an hour so at first they the first
response was doing install more signs
sort of warning of this curve ahead then
there were sort of larger signs then
larger flashing signs I know this was
seeming to have an effect so they the
final approach was to sort of paint
these transverse parallel bars on the
road that actually grow closer to one
another as you get closer to the curve
the sensation you have of driving over
it is that you're driving faster than
you actually are so it's they're
increasing your sense of risk without
actually increasing the risk it creates
the sort of a sense of confusion you
slow down accident rate has accordingly
Chicago Department transmission gone
down thirty-six percent they've actually
added some signage which has made it go
down even more but the key point is just
with this innovative paint treatment
they were able to effect a big sort of
change in that so you know and it's not
always about adding pain sometimes
removing paint is actually the answer a
street interesting study in England
looked at two roads trying to reduce
speeds on one Road so they took two
roads a sample road and this road and
actually removed the center line
markings and we've come to assume these
have a safety purpose and they make
things better for everyone but they
found if I'm removing the white lines
drivers actually drove further apart and
slower than they did on the road with
white lines which is exactly what they
were trying to do so just to conclude
here about sort of two thoughts /
centuries but sort of United that Sir
Isaac Newton and Henry Barnes former
traffic nursery or city which is just
you know a lot of Technology and
engineering and traffic world but
there's also a great importance on the
human factor which is something that
I've been trying to stress in my work
and I'll stop now and hopefully we'll
have a i'm sure a very productive
conversation thank you
you